a student accused in the latest deadly
attack on Jewish Americans allegedly was
inspired by other attacks on Jews and
Muslims the gunman killed one person and
wounded three others inside a Southern
California synagogue on Saturday night
witnesses say the woman who died 60
year-old Lori Gilbert case stood between
the shooter and a rabbi who had already
been wounded 19 year old John earnest is
charged with murder and attempted murder
and the hate crime investigation is
under way the attack happened six months
to the day after eleven people were
murdered at a Pittsburgh synagogue David
Pegg now is at the scene in Poway
northeast of San Diego David good
morning John good morning police believe
the gunman acted alone he had no
criminal history prior to this and he
may in fact be charged with a hate crime
you're about to hear from the rabbi who
was shot as well as the US Army veteran
who chased the gunman out of the
synagogue but we're gonna start right
now with what happened last night this
is what it looked like when the city of
Poway came together Sunday night to
start the process of healing being here
to support us the Jewish community
because we are all children of God the
Habad of Poway congregation was marking
the final day of Passover when police
say 19 year old John Ernest burst into
the synagogue and opened fire with an
assault-style rifle about 100 people
were inside and as I turned around I saw
the face of this murder of this
terrorist the gunman took aim at rabbi
he is Roy al goldstein who was preparing
to lead the service he suffered serious
injuries to his hands losing one index
finger could have gone right through my
chest
could have gone right through my heart
both fingers the gunman fired several
rounds before the gun jammed I don't
think I'm a brave person
Oscar Stewart says he saw Ernest opened
fire from the back of the room and he
ran toward him shouting at him that's
when Ernest turned around and ran they
say I saved lives I don't know if I
saved any lives I just I said what what
I did an off-duty Border Patrol agent
who had recently discovered his Jewish
roots was
so at the synagogue he fired at the
shooter hitting the gunman's vehicle as
the suspect drove away
authorities say Ernest ended up calling
9-1-1 himself and telling them where he
was about a mile from the synagogue
so our officer was actually in the
freeway he clearly saw the suspect his
vehicle suspect pulled over jumped out
of his car with his hands up the FBI has
joined the investigation police searched
the home Ernest shares with his parents
they're also reviewing an anti-semitic
manifesto that appears to be written by
the teen in which he said he was
inspired by last month's mass shooting
at a New Zealand mosque I had to look
the murderer in the face for something
for me to impart to the rest of the
world what is that to change it's time
for a change it's not just anti-semitism
it's all type of bigotry we have lost
our soul the rabbi told us he was so
afraid of violence happening here at his
synagogue he had asked that Border
Patrol agent to start carrying a weapon
every time he came to the synagogue in
fact the rabbi said that he had gone and
gotten a concealed carry permit but he
wasn't carrying a gun when the shooting
happened he told me last night he goes
after what happened I would like to
carry a weapon but then Anthony held his
his hand up and he said but the finger I
lost was my trigger finger David thank
you